lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo será
practicar la aplicación de la
sustitución o en una integral definida
digamos que tenemos la integral desde x
igual a 1 hasta ex igualados de 2x que
multiplica a x cuadrada más 1 esto
elevado al cubo de
así que ya te he dicho que voy a aplicar
una sustitución sin embargo es
importante ser capaz de saber cuándo
utilizarla en este caso la clave está en
que tengo es cuadrada más 1 y además
tengo su derivada que es 2x entonces
puedo hacer mi sustitución 1 y decir 1
va a ser igual a x cuadrada más 1 en
cuyo caso la derivada de eeuu con
respecto a x es igual a 2x y si lo
escribo en una forma diferencial obtengo
que la derivada de um es igual a 2x de x
ahora déjame sustituirla en esta
integral y en un segundo nos
preocuparemos porque es lo que le pasa a
los límites de integración y bueno me
quedan la integral de m
pongámoslo con el mismo color de un
elevado al cubo
esto es esta parte de aquí y después
tengo 2x de x y como todos están
multiplicando esto es lo mismo que d
observa esto que acabo de poner de color
verde es lo mismo que teníamos acá abajo
de un es igual a 2 x x de x así que nos
queda la integral de o elevado al cubo
de eeuu y bueno hasta aquí parece todo
fácil aunque nos quedamos con una
pregunta interesante porque ésta no es
una integral indefinida no queremos sólo
uso anti derivada también queremos
evaluarla en los límites de integración
así que qué les pasa a los límites de
integración bueno hay dos formas de
resolverlo
la primera es cambiando los límites de
integración porque este límite es de x
igual a 1 a x igualados pero ahora
estamos integrando con respecto a 1 así
que la primera de las formas si quieres
conservar esto como una integral
definida es cambiar los límites de
integración desde igual a algo hasta
igualar otro algo y veamos si x es igual
a 1 cuánto vale un
cuando x es igual a 11 va a ser igual a
1 elevado al cuadrado más uno lo cual es
2 entonces desde o igual a 2 y ahora
cuando x es igual a 2 cuanto es un bueno
tengo que es igual a 2 al cuadrado más
uno lo cual es 5 entonces hasta y igual
a 5 desde igualados hasta o igual a 5
tal vez no sea normal que se ponga que
va desde igualados a igual a 5
simplemente se ponen los límites de
integración pero hay que tener cuidado
con ellos o bueno simplemente podemos
poner la integral de 2 a 5 de un elevado
al cubo de
es importante que te des cuenta porque
cambie los límites de integración usamos
nuestra sustitución 1 para obtenerlos
cuando x es igual a 1 o vale 2 y cuando
x es igual a 2 o val de 5 y con esto
ahora si podemos resolver esta integral
de una manera sencilla tengo la anti
derivada de un elevado al cubo bueno
esto es muy fácil eso es elevado a la
cuarta entre 4 y vamos a evaluar esto en
5 y en 2 y entonces esto va a ser igual
a 5 elevado a la cuarta entre cuatro
menos dos elevado a la cuarta entre
cuatro y bueno puede simplificar esto si
quieres o simplemente obtener el
resultado de esta integral definida
bueno esta es la primera forma de
resolverlo pero me interesa ver la
segunda así que la segunda forma es la
siguiente primero hay que pensar en la
integral indefinida con respecto a
resolverla y cuando deshagas la
sustitución y usar los límites de
integración de nuevo los límites de
integración de x es decir qué tal si
primero intentamos resolver la integral
indefinida de 2x que multiplican a x
cuadrada más 1 esto elevado al cubo de
ok y después sea cual sea la solución de
esta integral de una manera algebraica
evaluarla en los límites de integración
es decir en x igualados tiene que es
igual a 1 bueno si usamos la misma
sustitución no vas a obtener que esta
integral es lo mismo que la integral de
un elevado al cubo de upp y claro sea
cual sea la respuesta vamos a evaluar
toda esta integral en x igualados y en x
igual a 1 y entonces esto va a ser igual
a veamos esto es un elevado en la cuarta
entre 4 y una vez más esto evaluado en x
igual a 2 y en next igual a 1 y ahora
podemos regresar a nuestra variable
original es decir deshacer la
sustitución o y recordar que valían x
cuadrada más 1 entonces esto me quedaría
como x cuadrada más 1 esto elevado a la
cuarta entre 4 esto evaluado en x
igualdad 2
n que es igual a 1 y ahora observa vamos
a llegar a lo mismo cuando pones x
igualdad todos obtienes 2 elevado al
cuadrado más uno lo cual de 5 esto
elevado en la cuarta potencia y eso
entre 4 y observa es justo lo que
tenemos acá arriba y esto menos un
elevado al cuadrado más 1 lo cual es 2
esto elevado en la cuarta potencia y eso
entre 4 que también es lo que tenemos
acá arriba así que de ambas formas
llegas al mismo resultado
puedes utilizar la integral definida y
cambiar los límites de integración
cuando hagas la sustitución 1 y obtener
la respuesta al evaluar y esa sería una
forma de resolverlo la primera o la otra
forma es resolver la integral indefinida
usando la sustitución o como paso
intermedio después regresar a nuestra
variable original y allí evaluar los
límites de integración iniciales y con
esto hemos terminado hasta la próxima